This is Jocko podcast number one oh six with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo and good evening.
Now in podcast one oh five we finished just as the one seven Cav flew out of the
eye Drang valley after keeping it together during a vicious three day fight
where they suffered to massive casualties,
79 killed in action,
121 wounded the dam.
And on top of that,
the battlefield was littered with enemy dead with the estimates of enemy dead to
be between 500 and a thousand and we stopped there where the where the one seven
Cav left the battlefield.
So if you haven't listened to one oh five yet,
go back and listen to that before continuing with this podcast.
One Oh six because even though the one seven left the battlefield,
the battle wasn't over yet,
and one of the,
one of the events that I didn't really talk about in the first I drank podcasts
on on one oh five was the fact that two other battalions had arrived on the
ground to reinforce the one seven and it was the second battalion fifth cavalry
commanded by Lieutenant Colonel Robert Tali and the second Battalion Seventh
Cavalry led by Lieutenant Colonel Robert Dade.
Okay.
Now most of the battalions men from those two battalions had landed at Lz
Victor,
which was about two miles away from x ray and they had patrolled to x ray on
foot arriving for the most part without incident.
And then things seemed to settle down a lot.
An x ray one seven left and once one seven had left the battlefield to seven and
two five we're still there.
Okay.
So at that point,
that portion of the battle was over and two,
seven and two five could have likely been extracted via helicopter pretty
securely.
Just at one seven had been,
it seems that General Westmoreland did not like the idea of two,
seven and two five pulling out.
He thought that that would appear as a retreat.
So he ordered that two,
five and two seven secure Lz x ray for the night,
and then the next day they would move by foot patrol to another LLC called Lz
Albany,
which was about 2.5 miles to the north.
And then B 52 bombers were going to rain down bombs on Lz x ray and the
surrounding areas.
They didn't expect a lot of resistance because things had settled somewhat down
so much on Lz x ray that if you remember,
even towards the end of the last podcast,
there was,
reporters came in and landed at Lz x Ray,
and we're doing camera shots and interviewing people.
So it was pretty settled down.
They felt like it was over and they didn't expect much resistance on this
movement from Lz x ray to Lz Albany.
Okay,
so let's go back to the book.
The book is we were soldiers once and young by General Hal Moore and Joe
Galloway.
And like I said,
there wasn't much resistance expected.
And here's what it says in the book.
The word among Bob McDade troopers was that it was going to be a walk in the
sun,
a stroll over to another landing zone where the helicopters would come in and
extract them.
The first leg of the journey home to on k base,
the word was wrong.
Okay.
And these guys,
even though there hadn't been much fighting going on,
they were actually a little bit tired because they had been awake on the ground.
So here we go.
Just before Alpha company,
second battalion moved out,
it's commander Captain Joe [inaudible] put out an unusual order.
His executive officer,
Lieutenant Larry Gwynn,
who we're going to hear a lot from lieutenant lyric.
Gwyn remembers it well,
the company had been on 100% alert for over 52 hours.
We were in such a state of exhaustion.
The captain's a denas directed that each man take two,
eight p c tablets,
aspirin with caffeine,
uh,
move designed to increase the mental alertness of the troops.
So there you go.
Take a little caffeine,
little aspirin,
get you guys,
get your head's in the game cause they'd been awake for a long time and again,
they're not expecting much,
but they still been on the ground in a hot Lz for awhile.
Back to the book,
Lieutenant Alley,
the battalions communication officer was with headquarters company.
We were told that this would be a tactical move.
There was a lot of stuff on the battlefield,
equipment supplies,
captured,
stuff that had to be policed it up and blown up all in a hurry up situation.
I was personally carrying an RC two 92 antenna in addition to my regular combat
load.
I weighed about 140 pounds.
My normal combat load was 40 or 50 pounds.
The two nine two antenna weighed 60 pounds.
The temperature must've been 96 and the humidity was the same.
We were moving as fast as we could through the elephant grass and scrub oaks,
some high canopy.
We were humping,
everyone was as tired as could.
So we're already in a rough situation.
We've been on the ground for 52 hours and we're going to move
two and a half miles.
Doesn't sound very far,
but when you're carrying,
so he's already,
he's carrying a hundred pounds is 40,
50 pound combat load pluses,
antenna and everyone else is carrying all kinds of extra stuff,
but they're pulling off the Lz.
It's 96 degrees out,
96% humidity and walking through the jungle is never easy.
It's up and down.
Little terrain features,
uh,
going through various foliage is hard.
So this is not easy.
Not the biggest guy to buy the 140 150 pounds,
which guys were smaller back then than they are now.
100 pounds.
That's,
that's no joke.
That's no joke.
Back to the book,
Lieutenant Gary Gwyn of Alpha Company says the jungle around us got heavier and
heavier.
That's when things got a little scary.
There was a sudden absence of any air cover.
The guys were silent and I wondered where our Hilos and our Air Ariel rocket
artillery ships were.
We had not changed formation tactically,
but physically we had to move in much tighter to maintain visual contact because
of the undergrowth.
The terrain forced our flaker flankers in.
So at this point there they,
they'd had a bunch of air cover,
they don't have any air cover right now and now the terrain is making them get
closer and closer together.
Because if you and I are on on patrol,
I don't,
I want to keep you in visual range.
I want to be able to see you.
And so if all of a sudden there's elephant grass,
well the only way to to keep visual of you is for you to get close to me and for
immediate close to the next guy.
And so everyone starts to compress and he's talking about the flankers being out
there.
A lot of times when we patrol information,
you'll put people out on the flanks within visual range,
but they'll be stretching the visual range,
but they're out there to make sure that there's no one sneaking up on you.
And so they've,
it's getting dense now to the point where they can't keep their flankers out.
So now you're losing some of that flank security.
Back to the book,
Gwen says,
Alpha Company's column order integrity had been good until two prisoners were
captured and everything came to a sudden Holt
when I arrived.
So Jeanie's,
sue Jeanie's was interrogating the two.
They were in mint condition,
new weapons,
grenades,
new gear,
but both were feverish,
terrified and shaking.
None of us in company headquarters had seen alive North Vietnamese up close.
These were not the last we would see this day.
We gave them water and advise the battalion headquarters.
So all of a sudden they got a couple of prisoners.
Little scary to me when the prisoners that we take have brand new weapons,
new grenades,
new gear,
I mean we at least know that they're fresh.
Maybe they're not combat hardened,
but we know that they've got some good no well supplied,
which is a scary thing in this type of war.
Hmm.
So this is,
this is kind of rear looking back,
hindsight of course being 2020 this is,
this is an error or a or a mistake that gets made right now.
And of course mistakes happen all the time and they don't get capitalized on by
the enemy.
Sometimes by luck,
sometimes by skill of the enemy.
This is one of those mistakes that it gets capitalized again,
whether it's by luck or plan,
probably by luck,
maybe it's a little bit of both.
You wouldn't think much of it if things didn't go the way they did.
You know,
late life.
And I used to have this conversation a lot.
I mean you don't know when things are going to go wrong and and seriously you
can be on the battlefield and you can,
you can say,
hey,
everyone go left and everyone goes left and everything turns out great.
Or you can say everyone would go right and everyone go right and everyone thing
turns out great.
If you go left and you happen to go to where the enemy was waiting in ambush for
you to go,
now you're,
you're,
you just made a bad tactical call.
The,
the thing that made it a bad town halls at the enemy happened to be there.
You couldn't know that.
Gotcha.
And if you'd have been,
if you'd said go right,
you'd made the greatest call ever because the enemy was over there waiting for,
again,
you don't know where the enemy is going to,
you don't have that luxury.
So sometimes you make the best tactical decision you can make and it turns out
bad.
Now we can look back at this hindsight being 2020 of course,
and,
and critique what's about to happen.
So we'll,
we'll,
we'll talk a little bit more about it.
Here's what goes down.
Back to the book,
Captain George Forest to commander of Alpha Company,
First Battalion Fifth Cavalry was more than 500 yards to the rear.
So these guys are in a long column of March Group of people.
Mcdade asked all the company commanders to come forward.
So McDaid is the company,
is the battalion commander.
And he tells all the companies commanders to come forward.
So he's McDade up at the front of this column and who knows how big they are.
You know,
he says he's 500 yards to rebut this pole thing probably spanned out
probably six 700 maybe even 800 meters.
We're getting close to a kilometer in length of people to spread out.
Just so everyone understands.
It's hard to control 40 guys in a,
in a line of March with any kind of control that spread out over 200 meters.
That's challenging.
You get 500 600 guys spread out over almost a kilometer.
We have a serious command and control issue.
So now what he's doing to overcome this issue is telling all the,
all the company commanders,
so there's three companies that are out there.
Actually there's more than that,
but there's multiple companies out there.
He tells all the company commanders,
Hey,
come to my position at the front of this thing so we can talk about what's
happening.
Back to the book,
Captain Fez Meyer,
the Charlie company commander,
was also moving up the count column to toward McDade position with him or his
two radio operators,
his artillery artillery,
Forward Observer,
Lieutenant Sydney Smith,
and his radio men as well as for first Franklin Hanse.
So,
so I want you to think about that or let me explain this to you a little bit
more.
Here's the Charlie company commander.
He's moving forward.
So he's leaving his company and with him he brings his two radio operators.
Hmm.
So who does that leave with a company?
There might be one platoon guy left that's a radio operator,
maybe one in each platoon.
But there,
there's,
he's pulling the,
the communications node out of the company right there.
He brings forward his artillery observer.
So this is the guy that's going to be able to place artillery.
Other guys can pick up the slack,
but not as well as this guy can do it.
Uh,
he brings Lieutenant Sydney Smith and his radio men.
So that means that,
so sorry,
the artillery observer is Lieutenant City Smith,
but that guy brings his radio mint as well.
So there's another guy out of the loop.
And then the first sergeant,
the company First Sergeant.
So now that's the leadership.
The company leadership is now from,
from Charlie company has now gone.
They're moving up forward to talk about it.
And so here,
uh,
they give a kind of an overview of what's going on.
Here it is.
This is what,
back to the book.
This is what was happening.
Sudanese Alpha company was moving forward toward the Albany clearing.
So they've,
they've now approached,
they're kind of approached this,
this Lz Albany.
That's what they're talking about.
The Albany clearing,
um,
Alpha company.
The genie's Alpha company was moving toward the Albany clearing.
Colonel Mcdade and his battalion command group were with Alpha Company.
The other company commanders had left their companies under orders and we're
moving up to join MCDADE for a conference.
So the other company commanders are not with their companies anymore.
The battalion was strung out along the line of March for a distance of at least
550 yards.
So half a kilometer.
The men of Delta company,
we're lolling around on the ground.
Charlie company had flankers off to each side,
but we're mostly taking a break,
a sitting or lying down.
George Forrest's men at the tail of the column,
we're in a wedge formation and also had flank security posted.
The Metta battalion were worn out after nearly 60 hours without sleep and four
hours of marching through difficult terrain visibility in the chest,
high elephant grass.
Was it very limited.
Okay.
Bad situation to be in.
Hmm.
Here's Lieutenant Gwinn talking.
We had been there a short time,
five minutes when I heard some rounds fired near our first platoon.
I thought they must have caught up with those Nva stragglers.
Then everything opened up,
opened up the firing,
just crescendoed.
They hadn't found the stragglers.
They had run right into the north Vietnamese.
I was out in the grass away from the trees when it started.
The rounds were so fast and furious overhead,
they were knocking bark off the trees.
I ran to them one round,
struck the tree.
I was crouched next to an inch over my head.
I said,
Holy Shit,
and ran to join Joel.
We all got down.
Then I heard this sickening.
Womp of mortar fire landing where I had seen our second platoon disappear.
Okay.
The most savage one day battle of the Vietnam War had just begun.
The second battalion,
seventh cavalry had walked into a Hornet's nest.
The North Vietnamese reserve force,
the 550 man,
eighth battalion,
66 regimen had been bivouacked in the woods off to the northeast of MC dates
column.
Yeah,
so you've got fresh soldiers that had been waiting.
They were the reserves.
That whole earlier battle and the,
I drank with the one seven Cav,
this,
this Vietnamese group,
the 66 regimen,
eighth battalion 1666 regimen had been waiting in reserve and now they just so
happened to be in the line of March where these were the two with a two five is
coming through.
Okay.
Or sorry,
the two seven is coming through.
Here's what Colonel Anne who,
again,
this was the Vietnamese commander.
Here's what he had to said.
Say I think this fight of November 17th was the most important of the entire
campaign.
I gave the order to my battalions.
When you meet the Americans,
divide yourself into many groups and attack the column from all directions and
divide the column into as many pieces.
Okay?
Move inside the column,
grabbed them by the belt and thus avoid casualties from the artillery and air.
Okay.
We had some advantages.
Now let me just talk about that one real quick.
Okay.
Two things.
First of all,
get the battalion split up right,
and if you here,
and I always talk about the common theme of keeping things together,
keeping people consolidated,
keeping your groups where they can mutually support each other.
His goal is the opposite of that.
Get them split up so they can't support each other.
That's number one.
So contrary to that,
what you should always be doing as a leader is trying to keep your forces as
consolidated as possible so that they can,
they can maneuver well together and most important support each other to cover
and move.
Now the second part of this is move inside the column,
grabbed them by the belt and thus avoid casualties from artillery and air.
That's something that we still see to this day.
We talked about it with the Cheshin conflict.
That was the Chechens mode of Operandi modus operandi to take to get inside and
be right next to the Russians.
They called it hugging.
They would get in there and and get in the same building as the Russians so you
can't call fire on your own building,
so that's what the,
that's what the Vietnamese were trying to do.
Now,
what's beautiful about these statements,
think about these two statements.
This is beautiful commander's intent.
Here's all I want you to do.
Split them up,
get close to him.
That's what I want you to do.
He's not saying how to do it.
He's not telling each individual group would where to move and what to do.
He is and split them up
and get close to them and stay close to him.
This is gives the guys on the battlefield incredible flexibility to execute that
plan.
Back to the book we had some advantages is on continuing.
We had some advantages.
We attacked your column from the sides at the moment of attack.
We were waiting for you.
This was our reserve battalion and they were just waiting for their turn.
The eight battalion had not been used in fighting in this campaign.
They were fresh Spec for Dick Ackerman was the right flank point man in the
recon platoon,
which was itself.
The point of the battalion says Ackerman,
we were going to the left to a clearing.
We had gone about a hundred feet when we heard some shots,
then more shots and finally all hell broke loose.
The main brunt of the attack was right where we had been standing.
Just a few minutes before we hit the dirt.
I was laying in the middle of a clearing and bullets were kicking dirt in my
eyes and breaking off the grass.
Ackerman's first sergeant was standing,
shouting and giving directions.
His shirt was off and he was in a tee shirt.
He lifted his left arm to point and I could see where a bullet had ripped him,
ripped open the side of his arm and part of the side of his chest.
He was still giving orders.
We were then ordered to another part of the circle that was weak.
It was facing the main area of attack.
There were people running everywhere.
We couldn't just open fire in that direction because our guys were there.
We were on semiautomatic and picking off whoever we could be sure of as a
target.
Okay,
so this just turns into he'll go immediately into chaos.
And again,
this is why consolidation of your forces is so important because the minute you
have an enemy in between you and other friendly forces,
your field of fire is completely shut off and you're unlikely when you're,
when you are pulling the trigger,
you have a good chance that you're going to shoot some of your own guys.
So that's what again,
why consolidations of forces is very,
very important.
Now I say this all the time,
I'll make the caveat again.
Are there times where you can get away with,
with splitting your forces and there's other times that it makes sense of?
Yes,
absolutely.
There are times that it makes sense and we did all kinds of operations overseas
where we had different units out on the battlefield that were split up and
maneuvering from different areas we did all the time.
But you have to know and understand the risks.
You have to know and understand the risks of splitting forces of having enemy in
between of trying to consolidate back together,
which is very,
very difficult.
You just have to really think about what the risks are and how you can mitigate
those risks.
Sometimes you can do it with a terrain feature.
You can put guys in a certain area where,
hey,
I have free fire because you're down behind a knoll or urine a ravine where I
know that I can't shoot you that.
That's the type of thing that you can do to mitigate,
but it is something that people think they can get away with and you know,
matter of fact we were doing
FTX sure.
And it was interesting.
We had one of the,
one of the females during the planning phase,
we have in plan just a a a couple operations just to sort of get used to
planning before we start the actual FTX.
This is for those who don't know.
We have a company called echelon front and sometimes we do field training
exercises with the companies we're working with.
To get them took to help instill in them the fundamental
principles of combat leadership.
So it was funny this,
this one female,
she had come up with this plan and they were going to enter this target building
from two different directions and tell him about the classroom,
the classroom portion of the day before.
And she actually,
I said,
well,
you know,
we've said keep it simple and it can be a little bit confusing if you start
entering a building from two different sides and you're now you've got guns
pointed at each other and you know,
you've got to be careful that you don't shoot each other.
And,
and she literally said,
I just don't see how it's going to happen that we could go into this building
and we're just going to start shooting each other.
Yeah,
of course.
Okay.
I smiled on the inside and said,
okay.
And,
and literally the next day during the FTX phase of the training,
which we're using,
uh,
air soft weapons and you're shooting at bad guys,
they came up with a plan,
entered a building from two sides and she entered the building and literally
shot one of her own people.
She did exactly what she didn't think could happen.
And that's what people have to understand.
Now you might think,
oh well it's this girl or this female.
And she was,
she's not a military person.
And it's,
you know,
that's why it happened.
No,
I saw seals do it on the regular,
you're all hyped up.
You go in that room,
you see a person moving crack,
crack him,
fire a couple of shots,
and then you realize what happened.
So,
so that's what's going on here.
Split forces.
Things are going crazy.
Now here we go.
Ackerman's back to the book.
Ackerman's recompile tune leader lieutenant pain.
He says,
all hell broke loose up along the north side of the ELC.
I turned to my right and observe some American soldiers moving toward the
northwest to set up positions and they went down in a hail of bullets.
Within minutes we were all under heavy attack and my radio operator and I were
pinned down in the middle of the Lz with the most of the fire with most of the
fire coming from the north and northwest lieutenant pains.
Radio Opera came alive as the Alpha Company platoon leaders reported heavy
fighting pain says mortar rounds began falling,
which was a new experience to everyone since we had never had any kind of mortar
fire against us.
The noise level was unbelievable.
I remember pressing my body flatter against the ground than I have ever been in
my life and thinking that certainly the highest thing sticking up where my heels
mortars continue to fall in small arms and machine gun fire continued at a
hectic pace.
Finally,
my mind seemed to adjust and I once again began to think about the situation we
were in and what we were going to do.
So you see there's a leader he's pinned down,
and this was something that,
that the insurgents in Iraq would do as well.
They're going to hit you with multiple different weapons systems,
you know,
in a combined coordinated attack.
So if you can imagine,
if you start hitting people with mortars,
well everyone needs to get down.
You need to get down,
you need to take cover while you're taking cover that cover.
They're gonna move,
they're going to maneuver in,
they're gonna maneuver in with with heavy weapons,
or they're going to move,
maneuver him with an assault squad,
or they're going to maneuver in with a vehicle borne IED.
So this is same thing happening here as you're getting mortared,
which these guys aren't used to,
which they're not,
that there's that much you can do to get used to it,
cause it doesn't matter.
It doesn't help you defend it.
You can be used to it.
You still have to get down and you still have to take cover.
These guys are taking cover.
And what I found interesting about this was you can see in his mind for a couple
seconds,
maybe 30 seconds,
he's just going,
holy crap.
I'm going to die.
And then finally he says,
my mind seemed to adjust and once again he'd be in.
Think about the situation we were in,
in what we're going to do now.
This is where combat experience is helpful.
If you haven't been in this situation before,
it's going to take you a few seconds to adapt and be like,
Oh Dang,
I need to do something.
If you haven't been in that situation before,
you could end up with some your,
it's going to take you some time to Justin,
it's like we talk about with self defense,
what Jujitsu.
If you've never been grabbed before and you've never been ground on before,
you've never had an humble,
someone pulled you before.
It's your mindset takes time just to get through that before you even start
thinking about actually defending yourself,
you're just getting used.
You're just saying a whole crap.
Why is this happening?
However you train all the time.
Then you're used to it.
You Go,
oh,
okay.
Someone's got me.
Here's what I'm gonna do to get out.
Same thing with getting punched in the face.
If you've never been punched in the face before,
it takes some getting used to.
You're going to get punched three,
four,
five times before.
You're like,
wait a second.
I needed to defend myself.
If you've been punched before,
boom,
oh,
I just got punched.
Here's my reaction.
Here's what I'm going to do,
and you'll,
speaking of Jujitsu,
going back to getting inside,
that's the same thing.
Getting close to someone.
What they were trying to do,
what the North Vietnamese were trying to do.
Get close,
stay close.
That's the same thing that you did too,
is you're trying to avoid the big punches.
You get in close,
you stay close,
you keep the person close to you.
That's how you avoid getting knocked out.
Same thing,
so train,
train hard.
Back to the book.
Alpha companies Alpha,
the Alpha Alpha Company's commander,
Captain [inaudible] Jeanie's was in the trees headed to where he had seen the
battalion command group disappear.
Just as I noticed a small clearing up ahead.
I heard one or two shots to my rear back where my first and second platoons
were.
I looked back,
there was a pause of several seconds and then slowly all hell began to break
loose.
I remember we were reading the book
okay.
By Ernie Pyle and he talked about the expression all hell broke loose because
we've,
we just heard it like five times.
Yeah.
And he's talking about how it gets overused,
but it's real and you can tell what these guys,
it's just absolutely real.
That all hell is breaking loose.
I don't want to say this too because I didn't mention this about Dade Mcdade
who's the battalion commander.
Mcdaid is the battalion commander.
He had just taken over the battalion like a few weeks before and he had moved
from some admin position inside the inside the,
the,
I don't know if it was inside the battalion or inside the brigade,
but he had moved from like a sort of an administrative position into battalion
command.
Hmm.
So in other words,
he wasn't charged of in charge of any troops and then all of a sudden he was in
charge of troops.
And then three weeks later they're going into combat.
Now that being said,
he also said that this guy hadn't been in charge of any troops in like 10 years.
So he,
he,
he had apparently done his platoon commander and his company commander in World
War two and Korea.
So McDaid is an experienced combat leader,
but he's out of practice.
Yeah.
He's out of practice and more probably more important or just as important to to
being out of practice is he just took over.
So part of being a battalion commander is that you train and prepare your troops
for combat.
You get to know all your man.
You get to understand their weaknesses.
You just can't jump in and take over and all of a sudden have the knowledge that
you would have if you were preparing everyone.
That's why training is so important.
That's why we train.
Yeah.
So if you are,
if you are not given the opportunity to train and learn your troops,
you're at a huge disadvantage.
You're an and you haven't had time to train them up to the year standards.
You know,
this guy was in World War II and Korea.
He understands combat.
And so to think that he wouldn't put his guys through a,
you know,
a certain level of training to get them up to speed and make sure they do things
like,
like make sure that there's uh,
uh,
other people in the chain of command that can step up and lead having a
succession plan.
So,
so like him calling people forward,
maybe if he had trained the battalion,
but he knew that there was other guys in there that we'll be able to take
charge.
He didn't realize that there wasn't like a little,
a little hesitation there that was going to happen,
which is what happens.
Yeah.
So he doesn't know his,
his team well enough.
Yeah.
For this situation.
And that's not good.
No.
Back to the book captain suit.
Jeanie's says Larry,
Gwen and I hit the edge of Albany on the northeast side of the clearing.
As the column began to receive intense fire,
we began receive sporadic sniper fire.
Part of the [inaudible] had already reached the island and the island that
they're talking about is there like an island of of woods,
an island of trees.
I yelled across the opening for someone to cover us.
We ran to the island at this point.
I called my first and second platoon's on the radio almost immediately.
I lost communications with first platoon.
The platoon sergeant for the second platoon came on the radio.
That was Sergeant First Class William,
a feral 38 from Stanton,
Tennessee.
He was a veteran of world war two and Korea had been a prisoner of war in Korea
and could have chosen to remain in the states.
He did not have to deploy with Vietnam with us.
Everyone called him.
Pappy.
Pharaoh kept asking captain [inaudible] where he was telling him that they were
mixed up with the north Vietnamese and had several wounded and killed.
I couldn't pinpoint his location.
I knew where he should have been directly east of our island,
pappy then radio that he was hit that there were three or four men with him all
hit.
I could hear the firing at his location over the radio.
I never heard from pappy again.
He did not survive.
Okay.
This confusion that happens is Fargo war stuff.
Yeah.
This is,
this is complete fog of war stuff and by the way,
the enemy gets a vote.
The enemy gets a vote.
The enemy can do things like this that you don't expect.
The enemy can hit you from multiple sides.
The enemy can have a strategy or a tactic to getting close.
That's what the enemy's going to do.
Okay.
You don't know what the enemy's going to do actually.
You don't know what they're gonna do.
You don't know that we're going to have mortars this time.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
Lieutenant Colonel Mcdade himself recalls when things began happening,
I got in with Alpha company.
I know.
I was trying to figure out what was going on.
I moved very fast.
Let's get over there in those trees and let's all get together.
The enemy seem to be all over the woods.
We had good tight control in the immediate area and we're trying to figure out
where everybody else was.
One of the things I was very concerned with was people being trigger happy and
just shooting up the grass.
I was telling them,
make sure you know what you are shooting at because we are scattered.
So notice how he says this.
We had good tight control in the immediate area and we're trying to figure out
where everyone else is.
This is horrible.
It shows you two things when you have good tight control over people,
you're okay.
Yeah.
If you know where your people are,
your okay.
There's one of the worst feelings on the battlefield is not knowing where your
guys are.
That is one of the worst feelings on the battlefield,
not knowing where your guys are
and sitting there trying to figure out where everyone else is,
which I guess those two are the same things and so the biggest concern he has
right now,
he's like,
he's so concerned about friendly fire.
Hmm.
Keep control of your people.
Back to the book.
The battalion operations officer,
captain spires believes that the,
the fact that the commanders were absent from their companies when the fight
started contributed to the confusion,
it had the most effect.
I think on Charlie company,
their commander,
Captain Skip Fest Meyer was up with us and Don Cornet,
the Charlie company executive officer was killed early on,
so they had no commander and they just disintegrated.
So leadership is the most important thing on the battlefield.
Talk about that all the time.
This is why,
this is why when you see a platoon or a company that doesn't have any
leadership,
they fall apart.
Now,
if you are well trained and if you have a good succession plan and if you've
done drills where the company commander gets killed and you take them out and
other people have to step up and lead,
yes,
that is how you prepare for these situations.
You have to prepare for those situations.
You have to prepare for leaders to go down.
Hmm.
But if you have no one that steps up,
you're going to be in a real hard way.
Real fast.
Back to the book.
The entire area was now alive with North Vietnamese soldiers who had obviously
cut through the battalion's line of March,
severing the head of the battalion from the body.
Gwyn saw three Gi gis coming through the high grass running from the area
swarming with enemy.
I jumped up and screamed to them,
waving my arm.
They saw me and headed directly to our position.
The first man was a captain,
our air force forward air controller who is completely spent.
I pointed out the Battalion Command Group,
which was huddled to our rear at the,
at another ant hill and he crawled toward them.
He was followed by the Battalion Sergeant Major Jim Scott,
who dropped down next to me and Scott was followed by a young,
very small PFC who is delirious and holding his guts in with his hands.
He kept asking,
are the helicopters coming?
I said,
yes.
Hang on.
The battalion commander initially thought that the incoming rounds were all
friendly fire.
So think about that.
The battalion commander on initially fought that the incoming rounds were all
friendly fire.
So what's his reaction?
Take cover.
Don't wish you back.
Mm.
Which is actually,
if you're getting maneuvered on by an enemy,
the worst possible thing you can do is take cover and not shoot back cause that
means the enemy's gonna maneuver faster on you.
Back to the book,
he had been hollering for all of us to cease fire and the word went out over the
command net,
but to no avail.
As the troops on the perimeter could see north Vietnamese,
can you imagine the confusion?
You've got the battalion commander on command that yelling to everyone to cease
fire and meanwhile you can literally see North Vietnamese and you're shooting in
engaging them.
This is me,
this is may him.
The sergeant major,
Major and I were looking to the rear.
When I heard a loud blast,
the sergeant major yelled,
I'm hit.
He had taken a round in the back under his armpit and there was a large hole
underneath his right arm.
I told him he would be okay to bandage it himself.
This he did ripping off his shirt.
Then he picked up his m 16 and headed back to one of the ant hills.
I saw the sergeant major a few times after that and he was fighting like a demon
sergeant major.
Scott says,
I took a bullet through my chest,
not more than 15 or 20 minutes into the battle.
I could see enemy soldiers to our left right and front in the in platoon and
company size elements.
They were up in trees up on top of ant hills and in the high grass.
We weren't exactly organized.
We didn't have time.
Everything happened all at once.
I didn't see a d a hole being dug up prior to 8:00 PM that night.
We did use the trees and ant hills for cover within a half an hour.
There was an attempt to organize groups in two defensive position in the company
area.
Individuals did this.
No one in particular.
I think that's what saved us.
So this is decentralized command coming at you.
The only thing that gets them together is that individuals stepped up and said,
okay,
we need a former perimeter defense.
Now,
unfortunately a half an hour,
an hour had already passed when they got to this point where the individual
start making the call.
The other thing is there's a lack of overall direction,
so you get to a point where if everyone knew,
hey,
here's what the position we're going to be in the battalion.
Here's our formation.
If something happens,
here's what we're going to do.
We're going to bound towards this area.
You,
there's all kinds of contingency plans that could have been done here.
No.
Again,
I'm doing hindsight 2020 which I hate doing,
but we are trying to learn and we are trying to talk to all the military people
that are listening that are out doing operations right now.
Think about this,
and I had this,
I probably told the story before,
but when we first got to Ramadi,
my one of the junior officers was taking a patrol out and it was a patrol
combined patrol with some Iraqi soldiers and some seals and he was going over
their patrol route with me and he got to this big open field and he said,
yeah,
then where to go?
We have to go across this field because it's the only way to get from here to
there.
And I said,
well,
what are you going to do when you get to the open field?
And he said,
well,
we're just gonna get across it.
It was how are you gonna get across it?
And he said,
well,
we're going to walk across it.
I said,
what if you get hit?
And he didn't really have an answer.
I said,
okay,
so here's what you're gonna do.
Leave some guys in the tree line over here.
Have these guys bound across to this little dyke right here.
Then those guys can join him.
Cover,
move,
just cover,
move across this field.
And that's what they did.
And sure enough,
they actually got hit.
They got hit with a pretty significant attack and uh,
with mortars and small arms fire and they covered,
moved out of the situation.
But my point is looking at the terrain beforehand,
having a plan and the next cute in the plan and dictating this situation you're
going to be in instead of letting the,
the situation dictate what happens to you.
Don't do that.
It's not a good answer.
Situation dictates.
That's not a good,
we dictate this situation.
Hmm.
Talked about it before
and then have your,
like the Vietnamese command was very broad.
The commander's intent.
Get close.
Split them up.
These guys didn't have a command like that.
What could the opposite?
Command a big bed stick together.
Stick together.
Keep integrity.
Well,
there you go.
Don't let them in clothes.
Okay.
There you go.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
Sue genies and Gwyn art agree that it was not long after this.
The Alpha,
the commander of Alpha Company's Missing Second Platoon Lieutenant Gordon Groves
staggered into the American position from the east.
Here's Larry Gwynne talking.
I saw Gordon Gordy grove coming across the field along with two wounded men.
They were the only ones left of his platoon who could move.
Grove was distraught.
We got him and his two men with us and our God,
our medics working on the wounded.
Then Gordy asked for men to go back with him to get his people.
Joel should Dinis said,
Gordy,
I can't send anybody about [inaudible] back out there.
It was clear that to leave this perimeter was deaf.
Everywhere you looked,
you could see north Vietnamese Gordy asked permission to go talk to the
battalion commander.
So Jeannie said,
go ahead.
He jogged over,
asked Mcdade for help to go get his men got a negative response.
So he came back to our anthill.
Yeah,
so this is one of those classic examples you hear about all the time.
People will try and get you in the,
uh,
the catch 22 question,
like the Gotcha question.
Well,
what would you do if you were in the situation and,
and you,
some of your guys were still out there,
but you didn't have enough people to go get him or you were being overwhelmed.
What would you do?
Well,
here's what these guys did right here.
They're like,
no,
you can't go get them.
Are you sending more people out there?
They're going to die if they die.
If we send 10 guys out there,
15 guys out there,
18 guys out there to go recover this plan,
we're going to lose 18 more guys.
We're going to stay put where to fight as best we can.
From here.
We'll get fire superiority back,
we'll get our shit together and then we'll go get these guys
Gwyn ads.
There was a tremendous battle going on in the vicinity of where we had come into
the clearing and beyond.
They're in the jungle.
He was Charlie company caught in the killing zone of the ambush fighting for its
life.
The mortar fire had ceased.
The enemy tubes apparently had been overrun by Charlie company B because we
found them all the next,
but
there were still hundreds of north Vietnamese calmly walking around the area we
were observing now began the sniping phase of our battle.
I call it that because for a long period of time all we did was pick off enemy
wandering around our perimeter and this lasted until we started getting air
support.
Everything that had happened to this point had probably taken less than 30
minutes.
Yeah.
Gwyn saw major Frank Henry,
the battalion executive officer lying on his back using the radio,
trying desperately to get some tactical air support and succeeding.
The air was on the way,
but there was no artillery or aerial rocket artillery yet Jim spires,
the s three ran over to us and query Gordon Grove Gordy Grove as the situation
outside the perimeter where he had just come from Grove,
told them they were still met out there,
tightened into a small perimeter,
but they were all wounded and dying in the radios,
had all been knocked out.
Captain spires asked a second time if you thought anyone was still alive and
none of us said anything.
Gwen climbed a top a termite hill and began sniping at the north Vietnamese
visible across the clearing in the trees to the south with Zm 16 rifle.
There were plenty of targets and I remember picking off 10 or 15 NVA from my
position.
Yeah.
My memories revolve around the way in which each enemy soldier felt that I hit.
Some would simply limp slump limply to the ground.
Some reacted as if they had been hit by a truck.
Some that I missed on the first and second shots kept on milling around until I
finally hit them.
What we did not know at the time was that they were wandering around the
elephant grass looking for Americans who were still alive and killing them off.
One by one
north Vietnamese soldiers climbed into trees and on top of those brush covered
termite hills and poured fire down on the cavalry troops.
Troopers trapped in the tall grass below them.
In the main body of the column,
there was serious firing,
including mortar fire from both sides.
The strike at the head of the column was followed so quickly by the enemy and
circling assaults that the whole business seemed to erupt almost simultaneously.
Okay?
Without doubt.
Some of some platoons of metates battalion were alert and in as secure a
formation as they could achieve in the elephant grass brush and thick scrub
trees.
But the visibility problem made it difficult to maintain formation and one
result was that American troop for close to one another then was tactically
sound providing juicy grenade,
juicy targets for a grenade,
mortar round or a burst from AK 47 rifle.
Okay.
All down the column,
platoon leaders,
sergeants,
radio operators and riflemen by the dozens were killed or wounded.
The first 10
minutes rapidly degrading communication,
cohesion and control
to this whole thing that we've talked about up to this point was like a half an
hour,
just a brutal on swap.
That debt kicked off with massive violence of action.
Captain Fez Meijer ads.
The result was very intense individual hand to hand combat in the confusion.
I had no idea exactly where the company was located.
When lieutenant cornet died,
it was virtually impossible for me to talk to anyone in my company.
The battle had clearly become an individual struggle for life.
Again,
that was the goal of the Vietnamese was to make it an individual struggle was to
get in close,
was to separate people from the main battalion to split it up into as many parts
as possible so they could pick it apart.
Spec for Jack Smith who was in Charlie company had been a radio operator until
about a week or so before this operation when he was shifted to a supply clerks
job.
The events of November 17 are etched on his mind.
Smith's company commander,
Captain Fas Meyer,
had like the other has been called to the front by Lieutenant Colonel Mcdade.
Subsequently,
many people pointed to this as a major error and in light of what has happened,
it was the firing began to roll on all around us.
The executive officer of my company,
a man called Dawn Cornet,
a very fine officer,
jumped up and in the best style of the infantry school yelled,
follow me.
Yeah.
Elements of our first and second platoon's ran right towards a series of ant
hills.
Within 10 feet of them we saw where the machine gunners behind them firing point
blank at us.
Men all around me began to fall like mown grass.
I had never seen people killed before.
They began to drop like flies and die right in front of me.
Okay.
These were the only friends I had and they were dying all around me.
Private First Class,
James H Schaden was in Forbes,
Delta company,
mortar platoon.
The intensity of the fire increased to the point where Shannon couldn't hear
anything but weapons firing.
Yeah.
And here's what he says.
Tone Johnson came crawling with me,
hitting the cheek and the back of the hand.
The trees were full of north Vietnamese,
but spotting one was almost impossible.
They blended in so well.
I kept raising up to try and detect a good target.
Matthew Shelton,
who was laying
next to me,
kept jerky me down.
As I raised up again,
a bullet pierced my helmet straight through front to back.
I went down again and came back and the,
and as I came back up,
a bullet struck the tree beside my head from behind.
I don't know where,
if we were surrounded or it was our own men,
they were firing wild.
Anything that moved,
somebody shot at it.
One trooper crawled up next to me shooting through the grass a few inches off
the ground toward where our own people lay.
Never thinking what he was doing.
I told him to be sure he knew what he was shooting at.
Yeah,
the firing eventually began to slack off shad and has no idea how much time
elapsed.
There was no way to keep track of time and a fight like this.
Okay.
Men were wounded and dead all in the area.
Six were alive that I know of.
Sergeant Tyler,
Pfc Carter,
Pfc Johnson,
Pfc Shelton,
Pfc cones,
and myself.
Tyler gave the only her order I heard during the entire fight try to pull back
before they finish us off.
Okay.
Shelton froze to the ground and would not move.
The five of us proceeded to try and pull back with the snipers were still in the
trees.
Soon I was hitting the right shoulder,
which for a time rendered it useless.
Tyler was hitting the neck about the same time he died an arm's length from me
begging for the medic Spec for William,
pleasant,
who is already dead.
Okay.
The last words Tyler ever spoke.
War.
I'm dying.
Yeah.
Sergeant Tyler 35 was from Columbia,
South Carolina.
The helplessness I felt is beyond description.
Within a few minutes I was hit again in the left knee.
The pain was unbearable.
Yeah,
Colin's who's hit in the feet and ankle.
We were wounded and trapped.
I could see we were getting wiped out.
Okay.
A buddy helped me bandage my leg.
He got the bandage off a dead Vietnamese.
I got behind a log and there was a Vietnamese,
they're busted up and dead.
This was behind us.
So I knew we were surrounded.
Okay.
It's
for me,
it's crazy to think these are Americans to really is,
you know,
it's,
it's crazy to think you,
you always think naive.
We sold that Americans have the upper hand all the time,
but you know,
here you are.
You do.
You don't,
you don't always have the upper hand.
Yeah.
Has,
she hadn't,
continues on.
It appears as if the ground was opening up and swallowing the mortar men.
They say they fell so fast.
Uh,
Brown wave of death rolled over them and on into Charlie company,
Vietnamese intermixed with them.
Then reality set in the enemy held ground beyond the outhill.
The column was cut in half.
Okay.
Incoming fire drew our attention back to the tree line.
The firing increased rapidly.
We returned fire at muzzle flashes.
I heard an explosion behind me turning.
I saw Chai,
calm grenades,
landing all flash and smoke,
no casualties.
The volume of fire became almost unendurable bullets,
peeled bark from trees,
vegetation disintegrated.
I look to Lieutenant James Lawrence for help saw as high his head violently
recoil.
He hit the ground.
Here's another description back to the book.
Here's what the Vietnam War looked like in the afternoon of November 17th
through the eyes of two of Captain Forest Alpha company rifleman,
Pfc David,
a Perp,
lavender of Murphysboro,
Illinois and Spec for James Young of Steelville,
Missouri says lavender.
My platoon was bringing up the rear.
Okay.
We started to maneuver and work our way up the column to help those ahead.
Every time we made a move,
we were hit by mortars.
It was something you can't describe.
People were dropping like flies.
The first blast killed a young soldier named Locatelli.
Every time we move,
they'd drop mortars on us.
I know we must have had 12 or 15 wounded out of our platoon,
including our platoon leader.
These were my buddies I had been with in the army for two years.
The majority of our whole battalion had been drafted at age 21 and had been the
service for over 18 months.
All of us were nearly 23 years old,
okay.
Debbie came my brothers,
over time
hearing these fellows scream,
hearing them killed,
stuck in my heart and mind ever since.
The most critical part of this flight was the beginning.
It was the surprise.
They had us in a u shaped ambush
and they had us cutoff with mortars,
surprise and violence of action,
surprise and violence of action.
Two key elements of firefights.
And here's what young said the other,
the other individual introduced a moment ago,
there was a grassy field to my left 25 or 30 yards and a sniper off on my right.
I couldn't see him,
but I saw a tracer bullet go across my hand,
okay?
I felt the wind of that bullet.
The same bullet passed over the back of Smith's neck.
He was lucky he had his head down.
Our company commander,
Captain Forest came running along our line.
He was stopping and telling everybody where to go.
He acted as though he was immune to enemy fire.
I don't know how he kept from getting hit.
Okay,
so captain forest stepping up and leading and what's
things do not happen without leadership so you,
unless he gets up and makes these things happen,
they are not going to happen.
That's what you do as a leader.
You have to make things happen.
Talk about it all the time.
There is an example of it.
Things do not happen unless you make them happen.
Now,
if you remember that oftentimes in Vietnam there would be a command and control
helicopter and we talked about this on one oh five where the brigade commander
actually came and landed for a little bit and then left.
Well that was Colonel Tim Brown and here we have a little section with talking
about what,
what's going on with him.
Back to the book,
Colonel Tim Brown's helicopter was running low on fuel and the chopper had to
return to refuel.
Brown says,
I knew they weren't a contact.
I did not know how severe or anything else while I was talking to Mcdade,
I could hear rifle fire,
but he didn't know what was happening.
I asked what happened to your lead unit?
He didn't know where's your trailing units?
He didn't know and he didn't know what happened to any of the rest of them.
Nobody knew what the hell was going on.
We were not in a position to shoot a bunch of artillery or airstrikes in there
because we didn't know where to put them.
Yeah.
Only now that Colonel Brown began rounding up reinforcements to send in to help
Bob Beck dates.
Second Battalion.
Yeah.
Did you notice what he wants to know is where people are?
Hmm.
That that's,
you've heard me talk about this before.
I used to ask the you dumb junior officers,
what's the most important piece of information you can have on the battlefield
and they'd sail where the enemy is and how,
how many there are and what kind of weapons there are and know the most
important piece of information there is on the battlefield is where you are.
And I actually tell the same thing to businesses because sometimes business is
don't know where they are because they're not tracking what they're doing.
So you're asking him,
hey,
where are you and you're in your p and l and your profit and loss.
They don't know.
You ask him where they're doing the nurse,
how were their sales performance is?
They don't know,
well,
how are we going to make any changes?
You need to know where you are.
Most
important piece of information there is,
here's McDade talking again,
this is the kernel or the battalion commander,
Lieutenant Colonel in charge on the ground.
In that first hour or so,
the situation was so fluid that I was acting more as a platoon leader.
Then a battalion commander,
that's a flag red flag,
right?
You're acting.
If you're acting as a platoon leader and you're in charge of a platoon is 40
guys,
a battalion is 500 600 and he's acting as a platoon leader who's running the
battalion.
We were trying to secure a perimeter.
I was trying to figure out what the hell was going on myself.
I don't think anybody in the battalion could have told you what the situation
really was at that time.
I can see where this might have left Tim Brown.
The brigade commander in the dark about what was going on.
I didn't know myself until things quieted down.
The Battalion Commander ads,
I could have yelled and screamed that we were in a death trap and all that crap,
but I didn't know it was as bad as it was.
I had no way of checking visually or physically by getting out of that
perimeter,
so all I could do is hope to get back in touch.
I wasn't going to screen that.
The Sky was falling and especially in a situation where nobody could do anything
about it anyways,
so if you don't know what's going on,
that means there's a bad problem that that that's,
that's my assessment and also it's also if you,
I'm not trying to say that you should cry wolf because you shouldn't,
but when things are going sideways,
okay,
you can wait for them to develop.
If you have a great grip of what's happening,
if you don't know what's happening,
you better spend some people up to come help you at least get him spinning.
At least get them turning.
That happens a lot where the guy on the ground might not fully understand what's
happening.
Make the call and say,
Hey,
I need,
I stand by it or support,
stand by,
get QRF spun up,
you know you make those calls.
That doesn't mean send to anybody but get them ready,
get them closer,
get them on standby QRF,
quick reaction force.
So if I'm on the ground all of a sudden are getting shot at from multiple
different directions.
I'm not really sure what's happening.
I might not say send the QRF but I'll say,
hey have the QRF move to position Alpha,
which is very close to where I am in case I do need them in 15 minutes or and a
half an hour or an hour or right now I've at least made that progression.
Is that like for just provide some general awareness?
Yeah,
so you're QRF quick reaction force.
They might be,
they might be 30 minutes away and they might need 15 minutes of notification
time.
Yeah.
Does that means if you called them right now,
they're going to be here in 45 minutes,
45 minutes from bad firefight.
Is not going to help you.
So your first call now you might bring them in and you preplan this.
This is when I talk about pre planning.
We would always preplanned,
hey,
if we need QRF,
we're going to call you to this point here.
We'll call you to this point here.
If we need to bring you on on standby,
we'll call you to this point.
Let's say this point is 500 meters away from where we actually are.
Yeah,
and then we have one that's right where we are like you come to this building,
if we call queue or after you come to this building,
we're going to try and get into that building.
If you don't hear from us and we just called for QRF,
come to that building will be inside it.
The best of our ability as they get closer,
hopefully you can establish communications with them directly,
but if you start losing control of the situation,
this is the thing.
When you start losing control of the situation,
you call it the QRF and say hey,
move to the staging point.
So now they're moving.
You Do,
you started that 45 minute clock right now they've all spun up.
They're all getting in their vehicles.
They woken up to the people that need to get out,
they get in their vehicles and they drive.
So now they might get to the 500 meters away and I had the situation under
control and I say,
hey,
we don't know if you come in,
we're okay.
Hold off on what you got there.
Bombed.
But they don't care.
They'd rather have that because maybe in 30 minutes things that develop to a
point where I need them and now they can get there in 15 minutes instead of in
45 yeah.
Okay.
So again,
we're not trying to spin up and waste assets,
right.
But in and actually know who did this,
a very similar in the,
in the previous podcast,
the guy that called broken Arrow,
which means troops are about to be overrun.
He didn't wait for anyone to tell me,
he just called it.
He's like k broken Arrow now.
It takes some time for those guys to show up there.
And by the time they got there,
they needed him.
Similar thing.
Now.
Yeah,
they don't advocate yelling or screaming.
Sometimes you might have to though,
you know,
you might need to get that information and people aren't paying attention.
What you're saying,
it can be impactful if you've ever been sitting in and it's in its operation
center where you hear people yelling,
it gets attention because most,
most military guys don't yell and scream for no reason.
They're yelling and screaming cause there's,
there's a reason why they're yelling and screaming.
Hmm.
Don't recommend it.
I don't recommend it,
but I've heard it.
You know,
I prefer the comm guys.
If you've got to yell and scream,
then calm down and talk about what you actually need.
You can't just continue to yell and scream because you'll,
you won't get through clear communication.
You'll come Austin office too emotional and you know,
you just become hard to understand when you're screaming and yelling,
calm down,
get their attention,
give simple,
clear,
concise direction of what you want.
Back to the book,
each and every man's still alive on that field.
American and North Vietnamese was fighting for his life in the tall grass.
It was nearly impossible for the soldiers if either side to identify friend or
fro accepted extremely close range Americans and all of drab and north
Vietnamese in mustard.
Brown were fighting and dying side by side.
It may have begun as a meeting engagement.
A hasty ambush or surprise attacked
a battle of maneuver and in fact it was all those things.
But within minutes the result was a wild may lay a shootout with just
gunfighters killing not only the enemy,
not only the enemy,
but sometimes their friends just a few feet away.
There would be no cheap victory here this day for either side.
There would be no victory at all.
Just the horrible certainty of death in the tall grass.
Unbelievable,
horrible,
horrible.
Back to the book,
just forward of the headquarters section of the column.
Charlie company was beginning to die.
Charlie Company's talking about Charlie Company.
A whole company meant 150 guys.
Spec for Jack Smith was with the lead elements in,
in the Charlie company formation,
nearly tenant.
Dawn Cornet,
the acting company commander.
When the company charged into the teeth of the enemy machine guns.
In the first seconds,
Smith saw one of the radio operators fall dead with a bullet through his chest,
his eyes and tongue of bulging out.
The men of Charlie company,
we're firing in all directions.
Smith recalls within a span of perhaps 20 minutes,
every one around me was dead or wounded except me.
You have to understand that in our area,
the elephant grass was chest high.
Once you hit the dirt,
your world was about as big as a dining room table.
Okay?
Your world's completely confined to that area and the six or seven men around
you.
Okay?
At that point,
we were isolated.
Alpha company was in the same shape.
Then the north Vietnamese swept through,
I believe they came between Alpha and our company began to shoot people.
We didn't know if the noise was from five feet away.
As they began to shoot,
people was friendly or enemy.
Yeah.
Smith saw soldiers take machine guns lie flat on the ground to begin firing into
the grass.
Often they were firing right into the muscles of other American machine guns.
People were screaming to stop the shooting.
It began to have all the elements of a massacre.
Okay.
Nobody was in control because all the officers were to the front and our radio
operators had fallen dead on their radio sets.
Okay.
No leadership,
no communication.
You know,
I talked to businesses and I explained this to my,
there's your point.
You hear it is loud and clear.
Tell these businesses where I go and talk to businesses,
they talk about this problem and that problem.
The other problem,
the problem is leadership.
That's what the problem is.
Okay.
The problem is leadership.
Yeah.
And this situation like this where the leaders are not there to lead.
You've got serious problems on your hands,
especially once again,
if you haven't trained people to lead to step up and lead when the leader's
gone.
Hmm.
If you haven't trained people to do that,
you're going to have problems.
No one is going to lead
back to the book.
Pain fought the north Vietnamese had done a match,
much jet or better job of anticipating and preparing for the attack,
but the Americans who survived the initial onslaught began to rally in one
respect.
You could think of it as little little big horn.
We were surrounded with our pacs in front of us shooting it out during the
course of that long afternoon,
I never saw a soldier not do his duty.
I never saw anyone who cowered in the face of the enemy.
Okay?
Our backs were against the wall and it was a matter of survival.
Every person I saw rose to the occasion,
so this is the American troopers are doing what American troopers do.
Fight
even in these terrible situation.
No one cowers.
No one stands down
back to the book.
Shortly after word of the command came over,
the battalion net throw smoke.
Lieutenant Gwinn moved a little away into the grass and the men in Albany
perimeter all began to throw smoke grenades.
I saw skip fas,
Meyer,
Charlie company commander throwing smoke.
I had no idea what the hell he was doing up here.
Our perimeter was marked with colors,
with all colors of smoke,
delineating our positions and shortly after the air strike started,
they were the,
they were a one e sky Raiders with napalm.
The first napalm canisters fell right at the point where some genius and I had
left the jungle and came into the clearing.
We could see masses of North Vietnamese on the other side.
I was sure.
I was very sure they were going to come across at us.
I think they were cleaning up over there,
shooting down at the ground,
dispatching our wounded.
That first strike was right on target with two napalm cans.
I saw them hit the tops of the trees and jellied napalm was coming down through
the limbs and the Nva were jumping,
trying to get away and being engulfed in flames.
I saw that time and time again.
Lieutenant Gwinn remembers a cleaned out swath after swath,
those fuckers would jump up and try to run.
They didn't make it by now.
The Americans were cheering and laughing at each strike.
The cheering stops when they dropped two canisters directly onto the position
where the remnants of the second platoon had been making their stand.
It might've been me,
but all I could hear was the cracking of unexpended rounds burning in the flames
that engulfed are men.
None of us know if there were any alive at the time,
but
none of us wanted to think about it.
Spec for Dick Ackerman of the reconstitution remembers our artillery was
supporting us so close that we would occasionally get some shrapnel.
There were planes flying,
close air support.
We started digging in everywhere we could.
My entrenching tool was attached to my pack,
left out in the clearing,
so I used my band at my fingers in someone else's tool when it was available.
The comfort of a trench just big enough to hold your body is unbelievable.
No more than 200 yards away.
In that tortured column,
a desperate Americans,
one man prayed for a miracle and the u s air force delivered it.
Pfc Jim Shaden Delta Company who had booby trapped his own body with a hand
grenade was badly wounded and unable,
unable to move.
He was directly in the path of a group of North Vietnamese soldiers,
methodically sweeping the ground,
killing his wounded buddies,
and here's what he says.
Before the North Vietnamese got to me,
half a dozen of them,
a pilot came over at tree top,
lever level turned straight up and drop the canister of napalm dead center on
them.
I never cease to be amazed,
amazed at the accuracy of that drop the heat of the napalm rolled across my face
and body like an open door on a furnace.
I owe this pilot more than it is possibly possible for a human to pay.
Yeah,
may God bless all pilots.
Now we hear from Captain Abuse Tallies.
Bravo company.
First Battalion Fifth Cavalry was a,
was assigned the mission of attacking to relieve the pressure and attempt to
link up with the beleaguered battalion ref reinforcements were also on the way
for the battalion command perimeter at the head of the column during the
afternoon.
Captain Myron to Derek's battle.
Wearied veterans of the fight at Atlantic zone x Ray Bravo company,
second Battalion Seventh Cav guiding a warning to prepare for a night air
assault into a hot landing zone.
The Bravo Company troopers delighted to have survived the hellish fighting on x
ray and enjoying a well deserved rest and a lot of cold beer back at Camp
Holloway were stunned when they were told they were being thrown back into a
desperate situation.
So suddenly,
so if you remembered to Derek from podcast one oh five from two seventies Bravo
company to seven,
they went in and helped turn the situation around at Lz x Ray.
They fought hard
and then they got extracted and now they're getting told,
oh,
there's a bad situation going on again and we needed to put you back on back in,
back on the flight.
Back to the book specialist John Worldliness,
Bravo company,
mortar observer was doing some serious celebrating.
He had not only survived x ray without a scratch,
but this day,
November 18th was his birthday.
I was 22 years old.
We were fed and showered.
New clothes were available.
I spent the afternoon at the men's,
at the enlisted men's club,
drinking beer with the platoon and exchanging stories and celebrating my
birthday.
Around 4:00 PM to Derek came in and told us to saddle up.
We were going to rescue the battalion
at about 1600 hours.
Lieutenant Rick Risk Score,
La recalls captain to Derek walked up,
get the company together.
Battalions catching hell.
We may have to go in.
You're the only platoon leader left and the company help all the platoons get
their shit together.
Men spilled out to the clubs and double timed their equipment.
They worked quickly throwing on their harnesses.
No protests but their eyes filled with disbelief again.
Did Derrick then issued the the shortest frag order and Bravo company history
will be landing from the southeast.
Open fired.
Anything on your left run to your right.
A hostile landing with one side of the landing zone held by the North Vietnamese
sit rep from the ground.
Grim expect to be sandwiched between friendly and enemy fires.
Okay.
At about 5:45 PM rest score,
La gathered the platoons.
They Preston close listening intently for word
Sergeant First Class,
Allston,
the mortar platoon sergeant,
Sergeant Staff Sergeant Martin Spec for Vincent Specialist Worldliness,
the towering sergeant leary Melton 80 or more young faces hollow wise.
Yeah.
Do you know the battalion and is in the shit?
I said we have been selected to jump into that shit and pull them out.
If you fight like you did an x ray,
you'll come through it.
Stay together.
Come out of those choppers.
Ready to get it on across the field.
The first lift ships were sweeping in head them up captain to direct grout.
I turned and walked ahead Fantino trailing with the PRC 25 the road stretched
out past the permanent hooches of the rear echelon at Holloway.
Word spread that we were on a suicide fight.
Tumbling out of cozy bunks.
Holloway's
finest line the road to watch us depart Hawaiian shirts,
aviator shades,
genes,
beer cans in hands,
cooks and bottle washers.
The ship Burgers,
Projectionists Club runners,
same army,
different species.
The company picked up pace,
a tight,
dirty brown column.
A few of the men carried a k trophies from x-ray.
No one had shaved noted risk score low,
but our weapons sparkled.
What outfit are you?
One spectator asked the hardcore of Bravo company.
Second of the seventh.
Where are you headed to kick ass?
I yelled back.
A deep rumble ran through the ranks.
Men Yelling,
cursing,
not a man among us would swap places with these large asses.
As we passed,
I asked Fan Tino,
how are we looking back there?
His reply,
no stragglers,
sir.
Every swinging Dick is with us.
As we made a column right to the pickup point,
I looked back at our crew.
No outfit in the army had ever rendered a route step any better than these men
at this moment.
Okay?
We piled onto the Hueys without the usual loading instructions and skated away
into the fading gray light.
Okay.
At 6:45 PM the first lift ships roared into the small Albany clearing and
captain to Derek's troopers bailed out into the tall grass.
The cavalry had written to the rescue,
but the killing and dying and terror continue to,
I'm baited in outside the American perimeter as the long night began.
Once again,
that's the American soldier right there.
Barely survive.
X Ray get called to go back in and they pick up the pace.
Yeah,
back to the book captain to Derek Road of the flight in and the situation on the
ground or assaulting Albany.
We picked up five bullet holes in the helicopter.
Things were bad.
I found out when I landed that the battalion was shot up pretty bad,
so we came in the nick of time.
Did they rescue the main part of second battalion?
Seventh CAV was on their last ditch.
Standard Albany little big horn revisited
and here's Russ score talking,
looking sideways.
I saw a trickle of blood down the pilot sleeve.
This is as they're flying in,
the choppers dropped a few feet.
The pilot yelled at the gunner,
the gunner smelled.
Get Out.
I hesitated,
get the fuck out.
Four of us dropped the bone jarring 10 feet.
Now inside the battalion command group,
perimeter rescue,
Orla took stock and here's what he says.
The battalion sergeant major sat against a tree with a bandage chest.
We got hit bad,
sir.
Real bad.
The wounded were gathered 30 yards from the CP.
Only half my platoon had arrived.
The other ships turn back because of the ground fire and darkness.
Yeah.
The perimeter was an oval island of trees.
Three platoons could man the perimeter,
but with the exception of our people and pat pains,
recompile tune,
there was no unit cohesion.
Okay?
Colonel McDade slumped against a tree.
He looked exhausted.
He was exceptionally silent.
Major Frank Henry,
his executive officer was reassuringly active.
A short fireplug of a man.
Henry waved a welcome working the radios.
Captain Joe Price,
the fire support coordinated coordinator Crouch beside him.
Clumps of survivors sprawled inside the perimeter,
including several company commanders.
Okay.
Lieutenant Larry.
Gwen watched the reinforcements arrived.
I saw Rick risk score law come swaggering into our lines with a smile on his
face and [inaudible] on his shoulder and his m 16 in one hand saying,
good,
good.
I hope they hit us with everything they've got tonight.
We'll wipe them up.
His spirit was catching.
The troops were cheering as each load came in and we really raised a racket.
The enemy must have fought that an entire battalion was coming to help because
of all are screaming and yelling.
Okay.
Major Henry directed that.
I round up some men and police all the ammo resupply,
which the choppers brought in on the last flight.
Yeah.
He was lying in crates on the far side of the ELC.
Somehow we got it all into the perimeter.
As I came back with the last load,
I passed right over the body of that North Vietnamese.
I'd killed early in the fight.
Yeah.
There wasn't much of him left and I didn't give a damn.
Yeah,
so
I mean there you go.
There you see one.
One liter makes a difference.
One liter makes a difference here.
These guys are completely surrounded,
dead and wounded everywhere,
and Rick Ross score luck comes in and says,
good,
I hope they bring it tonight.
We'll wipe them out.
Back to the book.
Lieutenant Pat paid of the [inaudible] tune was just as happy about the
reinforcements as Quinn.
We were all very surprised to see those helicopters come in.
We were only securing one side of the Lz,
so when the guys would jump off the helicopter,
we hollered at them,
which way to come.
Okay.
I had a feeling we'd actually been rescued that in the fact that the cavalry had
arrived.
Just like in the movies,
I admired the courage it took to land in Albany.
Lieutenant Rusk score was one of the best combat leaders I ever saw during two
tours in Vietnam.
He walked around at pepped,
everyone up by telling them they've done a good job,
that there was support.
Now that things were under control,
he never raised his voice,
almost spoken of whisper.
We're awfully glad to see him and the others from Bravo company,
well got in there and told everyone are you did a good job.
Didn't get all negative.
Although he's actually,
and he talks about it and I think,
I think I'm going to cover it,
but he talks about what he was actually thinking was like,
this is going to be really problematic.
In his mind,
he was thinking,
this is bad,
really bad,
but he didn't show that.
He showed,
hey,
we're good.
Bring it.
You're,
you're,
you're good now.
Good job.
Get ready to get it on.
Talking a little bit about the,
the air support that they're getting.
Back to the book chief warrant officer Hank Ainsworth had been overhead in the
second Battalion Command chopper all day and here's what he says.
I was overhead when the fight started in orbited overhead to late that night.
I was on a freak talking to major Frank Henry.
Later that evening,
he called me.
Henry said,
we have critically wounded down here.
If we don't get them out,
they're going to die.
I called Medivac and they came out,
made a pass,
drew fire and refuse to land to land.
Frank Henry knew exactly what to do about that situation.
He told Hank Ainsworth to call the 229th Huey slicks the old reliables Ainsworth
notified the two 29th pilots told them that Lz Albany was hot,
but that second battalion,
seventh cavalry had critically wounded men who would die if there were not
evacuated.
Says Ainsworth the whole damn unit volunteered.
I told them we only needed two ships despite Ainsworth's call for only two ships
for Huey slicks lifted off from Camp Holloway Turkey farm at 9:50 PM for the 40
minute flight to Albany.
Captain Bob Stinnette was again in the lead followed by a captain Bruce Thomas,
Chief Warrant Officer Can Faba and Warren Officer Robert Mason,
and here's what stinnette says.
Normally the Huey pilot's throttle back their engine to as soon as they touch
down to conserve fuel fuel.
Not Tonight.
Something told me not to do that,
to keep the engine turning at a full flight.
Rpms.
They told us the wounded war ambulatory when we got in there,
they were all stretched your cases,
my crew chief and Gunnar had to get out and raise the seats so we could get all
the stretchers in.
Then all hell broke.
Loose.
Fire was coming in from everywhere.
I immediately pitched.
I immediately pulled pitched and with the Rpms at flight,
the ship instantly jump 30 feet in the air and kept going up.
We went so fast that the crew chief and gunner got left behind on the ground and
I'd even know it.
We just flat left them.
We had the wounded inside.
When we got back,
we counted 30 holes in my machine.
That was enough for me and my Huey,
the lift of three that went in after dog after me took in medical stuff and
brought back more wounded and my crew major,
Frank Henry was on the flashlight at the time.
Joel [inaudible] watched it with awes,
the brave aviators wrist,
everything for the wounded at Albany.
I remember thinking they were the bravest pilots I'd ever seen.
They were sitting docks and I fully expected to see them shot down at any
moment.
They were guided in by Frank Henry.
You could see the tracers.
The aircraft didn't hesitate a bit.
They landed loaded and we're gone in seconds.
So again,
you see what w that's the American fighting spirit.
Oh,
we got a hot LZ where we probably going to get shot down,
but we've got wounded Americans on the ground.
We're going to get them.
Everyone in the unit volunteers.
We only need two aircraft guests.
What we're bringing four.
Okay.
Back to the book.
After midnight,
several shots rang out from inside the perimeter,
a trooper 20 yards behind risk score low inside the perimeter had rattled off a
panic.
He three rounds rest score low,
walked back and cost out the group in the middle of the perimeter.
If I hear one more round out to you,
we will turn our weapons around and open up.
No one fires from inside the perimeter.
If you want to fire out to the perimeter,
if you want to fire,
get out to the perimeter line whispered.
Communication took place all night between isolated elements outside the
perimeter.
If there was heroism,
it was out there in the tiny groups of wounded and those who had bandaged and
protected them through the night.
Yeah,
they were just like hunting buddies said Russ Korla surviving by instinct,
looking out for each other.
Okay.
Lieutenant Larry Gwyn of Alpha company recalls that late that night,
one of Alphas missing men crawled into the American perimeter.
And here's what he says.
Sergeant James,
a Malarkey from our first platoon made it back to our lines,
his story.
The NVA had been shooting our wounded one came up to him,
stuck a pistol in his mouth and fired the bullet,
exited through the back of his throat,
knocked him out,
and they left him for dead.
Yeah,
he survived.
And when he woke up that night,
he started crawling to us.
Okay.
The next day was a real nightmare as we went out to find our dead and missing.
I think each of us cracked up a little bit that day.
As the true picture of the action began to unfold,
then it came across the radio.
Bravo company had found an one other survivor from our second platoon.
He had been badly wounded in the legs and it propped himself up against a tree.
He had been burned by napalm waiting in the night and some north Vietnamese had
put a pistol to his eye and pulled the trigger,
shot him in the eye,
blinded him,
but he was still alive.
I saw him being brought in by stretcher,
smoking a cigarette,
all fucked up.
So at this point,
things had backed off a little bit.
They backed off and they actually did the mad minute,
which is something that Hackworth talks about and it's something that they did
in the first part of this book,
which is,
Hey,
everyone in the perimeter is just going to shoot a bunch of rounds like at six
30 in the morning,
boom,
everyone fire a full load out or a full magazine or a couple magazines at likely
targets
and they did that and that seemed to calm things down.
They kind of did that once things had already calmed down a little bit and
yeah,
it was,
it was.
It indicated that maybe things were calming down a letter.
Here's another thing.
Back to the book,
the Nva came into the ambush area that night to to recover their dead wounded.
When they found any of our guys alive,
they would beat them to death bayonet them or machete them to avoid shooting and
drawing fire from us.
That was during the night.
They did that.
Like I said,
they did the madmen and here's what,
here's what lieutenant risk score Orla said about the mad minute.
He said,
this decision was regrettable rifle fire shattered the silence and the perimeter
was ringed with reckless firing.
Little fought had been given that the remainder of our survivors were sprawled
among the trees and ant hills within 500 yards.
The effective range of RM sixteens.
What the fuck is happening?
Are you shooting at us?
The frantic radio calls started coming in.
Okay.
How many troops were killed or injured by our wake up call?
We'll never be known.
Thank God for the trees,
the ant hills and the on even terrain.
Okay.
Captain at Dudley to de mi,
Third Brigade Fire Support Coordinator remembers flying out to Albany at first
light the next morning.
Tim Brown,
myself,
Mickey parish took a while to get through the smoke hanging over the whole area.
Not much had really taken place in terms of policing the area.
The image is still vivid in my mind is the carnage folks.
We're still sitting around in a daze.
They hadn't done much,
hadn't even taken ponchos and covered up these bodies.
Okay.
I could handle the conversation.
I could handle grown men crying,
but we were talking 12 hours later,
okay.
Sitting there feeling sorry for themselves.
Colonel Brown was very pissed off.
Even if you do get caught in a bad situation,
you have to do something to recover.
It was young kids who paid the price in later years.
I used to stress that to my young battery commanders.
It isn't us who die in combat.
It's those young kids who die.
Those kids,
we are responsible for training and leading.
It's our job to get the job done and get those kids home safe.
Then here,
they're wrapping up this again.
Now this the battle turned and and really the Vietnamese laughed after these
massive airstrikes.
It started
and
here's another image of the cleanup back to the book specialist for John
Wooliness of Bravo Company,
second battalion,
Seventh Cavalry Mortar Platoon,
and most of the rest of [inaudible] men were involved in this McCobb depressing
duty.
It was incredible carnage.
We went into areas where lots of artillery had come in during the night and we
saw our guys had been blown up in the trees.
The bodies were already decomposed and it had only happened night before.
Yeah,
we were in shock.
It was the first,
last and only time I ever saw anything like it and I pray never again.
Okay.
The stench was unbelievable.
We started hauling in the whole body's first.
Then we brought in the pieces and parts
two chinooks came in and we loaded one with about 20 corpses neatly arranged in
litters.
Yeah.
The pilot began preparing to take off.
One of our officers pointed him 16 at the pilot and told him to keep the board
on the ground.
We weren't through.
Yeah,
bodies were loaded floor to ceiling.
When the ramp find the closed blood poured through the hinges,
I felt sorry for the poor bastards who would have to unload this chopper back at
Holloway.
The nightmares bored of this battle have never faded him.
The
final division headquarters account
reported that the two seven Alpha and Bravo companies and the one five battalion
suffered 151 men killed in action,
121 wounded and for missing in action.
And on April 6th,
1966 so quite some months later,
how Moore who was at that time had become the third brigade commander,
went back to Lz Albany and recovered the bodies of all four members of two,
seven who were
brought back on a Hilo and begin the
long journey home to America.
Now this was,
as I said,
kind of the,
the tipping point in the Vietnam War.
And this battle had a impact strategically.
One thing that came from this battle,
and it'll talk about a little bit more in the book,
but the body count came back and the body cam came back basically as 10 to one
or maybe 12 to one.
So for every 10 or 12 north Vietnamese soldier that was dead,
there was only one American guild.
And our generals liked that ratio.
They thought,
hey,
you know,
we can win a war of attrition.
And
one of the comments that comes in in the book as they go back in and interview
General Gi App,
who's the,
the senior general of the North Vietnamese army,
and he's got a book actually that we're going to do on the podcast at some
point,
he's the mastermind or the strategy,
and he said,
we thought that the Americans must have a strategy.
We did.
We had the strategy of a people's war.
No,
part of what that means is that the strategy of the people's war means we're
going to,
we're going to suffer some casualties,
and we're okay with that.
So our strategy of saying,
well,
we'll get them into a war of attrition and were okay with it.
They don't care.
Human life has less human.
A human life has less value for them at this time.
They,
they're the commanders sure as hell didn't care.
You know,
we talked about that last time.
They're losing guys on the,
from malaria on the trail,
you're going to lose five,
six guys.
They don't care.
They've got a war to win.
So talking about some of the other sort of strategic things or strategic
implications from this.
MMM.
Night 1967 so this is a couple of years later,
back to the book.
In mid December,
President Johnson convened a White House meeting of his top advisors.
Will Bundy says that McNamara is option number one get the hell out of Vietnam.
Now,
while the getting is good was never seriously considered,
nor was it pressed by Mcnamara.
Option number two,
the huge buildup of American combat and support troops was readily approved by
all including Mcnamara
ever.
The numbers cruncher Mcnamara told the gathering the military solution to the
problem is not certain the odds of success are one out of three or one out of
two
Mcnamara did push for a bombing pause to prepare us opinion,
public opinion for the combing escalation.
So
again,
we'll,
I'm sure at some point on this podcast we will dive deep into the political
okay
manipulation,
the political decision making that happened during the Vietnam War.
But this is,
this is what they're talking about.
It's interesting to hear McNamara even back in 1967 to saying,
hey,
we got like a one in three,
maybe one and two odds of winning.
Okay,
does this not?
That's not,
that's not good odds.
We don't like those odds.
Yeah.
Here's,
here's how more talking again,
back to the book in late June,
1966 my turn was up as commander of the Third Brigade when my replacement or
colonel straight out of the Pentagon showed up to take over.
My Brigade was in the field fighting near Dong tray.
It would have been criminal in those circumstances to relinquish my command to
them.
Two man who still,
who still pissing state side water and I flatly refuse to do so.
The change of command was delayed 10 days until the fight was over.
A month later on August 8th,
1966 my replacement's sent my replacement,
sent Alpha Company,
First Battalion Seventh Cavalry back in the I drank valley by itself and 25 men
were killed in one terrible day.
So not a good turnover situation.
And again,
this is where,
this is where the beer,
people always talk about what I talked with businesses.
They go,
we have a big bureaucracy here that you don't understand.
Like,
no,
we understand the military understands pornography better than anybody.
We probably got the biggest and most most firm in place,
bureaucracy in the world.
Hmm,
and this is part of it right here.
Back to the book.
I had hope that my next assignment would be to the infantry school at Fort
Benning where I could pass along what I learned in Vietnam for the young
officers who are headed for combat.
It was not to be,
in fact only one of the hundreds of officers who had gone through air mobile
trading and a year in the field with the First Cavalry Division was assigned to
the infantry school.
I was sent instead to Washington DC where I was told my neck next job would be
Latin American desk at the US State Department.
This is,
this is an embarrassment,
right?
Here's this guy basically created or helped create or help test the,
the idea of air mobile,
helicopter assault.
And then he did it for a year in the field,
commanded at the battalion and that the brigade level,
and instead of putting them in the infantry score,
he could teach the stuff that he learned.
They send them to be the,
the,
the Latin American desk.
Yeah.
And I'll tell you what's awesome.
This was awesome when I was in the seal teams,
I went to [inaudible] when I came home,
guess where I went?
I took over the west coast seal training for the guys that were getting ready to
deploy to Iraq and Afghanistan.
I did what he wanted to do,
which is perfect.
And then luckily we have the little,
a little less bureaucracy.
I was able to talk to my boss and say,
Hey,
this is what I should be doing.
He said,
yeah,
you're right.
And put me in that position.
Okay.
But it didn't happen and here's all this knowledge going.
And they said,
only one officer out of a hundred.
Hmm.
That's another thing,
like when you hear,
you know,
people in the business world,
they say,
well,
the military is this great organization.
The military has all kinds of problems.
Hmm.
Military is no perfect,
no perfect example of the way to run things.
Parts of it are,
hmm.
But you can't look at the military to whole and say that that even remotely make
sense in any way,
shape or form.
And I could point a thousand things out to you today.
The military is the same way,
doing dumb stuff.
I mean,
it's a great organization,
has got great people.
There's,
there's unbelievable leaders in there,
but there's also idiots.
Mm.
The military is made up of people of human beings.
Brilliant.
Once dumb ones.
Back to the book for the next year,
I watched Bob Mcnamara and John McNaughton,
both brilliant men go through hell as they struggled unsuccessfully to get a
handle on the war and the pacification progress in Vietnam.
Okay.
At the end of that year,
neither of them was either.
Neither of them was any closer to finding or creating such a handle.
Okay.
An office wit summed up what was happening in Vietnam,
sadly and succinctly.
Okay.
Although we have redoubled our efforts,
we have lost sight of our objective to a porn.
All this troops in there,
porn,
oldest money in there,
putting all this,
all these assets in there.
We've,
we've redoubled our efforts,
but we've lost sight of our objective.
Back to the book.
What then had we learned with our sacrifices in the,
I drank valley.
Okay.
We had learned something about fighting the north Vietnamese regulars and
something important about ourselves.
We could stand against the finest light infantry troops in the world and hold
our ground.
Okay.
General Westmoreland fought.
He had found the answer to the question of how to win this war.
He would train one American life for 10 or 11 or 12 north Vietnamese lives day
after day until [inaudible] cried.
Uncle
Westmoreland would learn too late.
Yeah.
That he was wrong.
That the American people didn't see a kill ratio of 10 to one or even 20 to one
as any kind of bargain.
Yeah.
But we had validated both the principal and the practice of air mobile warfare.
1 million American soldiers would ride to battle Huey helicopters
for the next eight years and the familiar wa Wah will have their rotors would be
the enduring soundtrack of this war.
Finally,
even though it took 10 years,
cost the lives of 58,000 young Americans and flicked it humiliating defeat on a
nation that had never before lost a war.
Some of US learned that Clausewitz had it right on hundred and 50 years earlier
when he wrote these words,
okay,
no one starts a war or rather,
no one in his senses ought to do so without first being clear in his mind what
he intends to achieve by that war and how he intends to conduct it.
Okay.
Clausewitz
to be clear in your mind,
in what you intend to achieve.
No.
What you are going to do that doesn't seem like too much to ask.
Certainly in war
and you wouldn't think it would be too much for people to ask in their lives
either.
They're precious lives as precious as these 58,000
okay.
That died in Vietnam
heroes,
but how often do we see people going through their lives without knowing what
they are trying to do without having any intent,
without having a clear mission.
I'm talking to on an individual level as a person,
people go through their lives without knowing what it is they want to do,
what they want to accomplish.
So know what your mission is,
know what your intent as the commander of your life,
know what your intent is and then fight with everything you've got
to win.
Yeah,
and I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So
that go maybe if you want to
shed some light on how people can
maybe help themselves a win that war and maybe support the podcast if they want
to.
They want to
that point though,
in my opinion is a good,
it's a good one.
It's a good way to think about you.
People go through the lines,
I don't even know what they're trying to do.
Yeah.
And it sounds the same thing as going to war without knowing what the outcome is
supposed to be.
Yeah.
Goal.
But it sounds kind of like a bs when you say it,
you know,
like,
Hey,
go through.
Like,
you know,
when you go through life,
should you have a goal,
a real obvious yes.
You're going to say,
no,
you shouldn't have a goal kind of thing.
So it seems obvious,
but you know how you live day to day.
You,
you know,
you might have a goal for the day,
maybe two,
maybe three,
but Brett life is for life is a full spectrum of stuff we're or get.
It's so shocking because what you're saying is absolutely true.
You wouldn't think that people would be going through life without knowing where
they're trying to get to yet.
But you wouldn't think that a nation would go to war without clear intention of
where they want to end up and how they're going to get there.
At least an idea of how are you gonna get there.
Now I have a little bit of like when Klaus Fitz says how you're going to conduct
a war,
that's not necessarily true because you don't know.
You can't know how you're going to conduct a war before the war starts and you
can have an idea,
but you can't know fully.
Just like if you were to say,
Hey,
my goal is to x in my life and you don't know how you're going to be able to do
that because he's talking about,
because you've got to adjust because you're going to make an adaptation as
things are going to come up,
things are gonna change.
The battlefield changes,
your life changes,
things pop up.
I mean,
things happen.
So I think that that idea that you're going to know how you're going to execute
something is,
is farfetched.
I think actually I should use the word idea.
You should have an idea of how you're going to do it.
Yeah.
You just have an idea like,
okay,
well this is what I need to get done.
This is what I want to achieve in my life.
Yeah.
I want to make,
I want to do this.
What's a simple one?
I want to own a house.
That's a simple one.
That's a good place to start.
I want to own a house.
Okay.
Well,
let's think about how we're going to get there.
You know,
that's,
let's think about how we're going to get there.
You have to build your credit.
You have to,
how do you build your credit?
you have to borrow money.
Some people,
some people,
they go to buy a house.
They've never borrowed money before.
You can't borrow money if you've never borrowed money.
You can borrow money for a house if you've never borrowed money for a car or a
or a or some smaller object before,
so you've got to establish your credit.
Then you've got to have two years worth of income.
Then you've got to have a big fat down payments and rent,
so there's things you got to do this thing now.
Now that might change along the way.
The idea is that you've got to move towards that goal,
but that's what was so nice about hearing the Vietnamese commander's intent.
Get close,
split them up.
Boom.
You go make that happen.
Hey,
guess what?
You want to buy a house one day?
Save money.
Have good credit.
Yeah.
Okay,
well you got to make money.
How you can make money.
You might make it drive an Uber.
You might make it delivering pizza.
You might make,
cause you got your real job,
but that support in your family,
but then you need a little extra to throw in there.
Well that's why you end up driving Uber or you end up with whatever it is you're
going to do.
Are you ready to be to make your some money on the side that you can start
stashing away?
Yeah.
At the end of the day,
you do have that goal,
you know,
so it is,
yeah.
How you conduct yourself.
It's not gonna be cut and dry for sure.
But you know,
in these examples like uh,
you know,
you want to buy a house,
that's a goal.
That's a specific goal.
But that's just one teeny tiny goal in life.
If you're,
of course you're not going to run into somebody who their only goal in life is
to buy a house.
No,
no,
no.
I said a civil war.
Yeah.
It cause some people like,
hey don't buy a house.
It's stupid.
You should rent and stuff.
That's fine.
I'm not telling everyone what their goal should be.
And if you want to keep renting,
keep renting.
Maybe that's for you.
Yeah.
Fully.
Not for me yet.
Maybe it's for you.
There's other things you want to put your money.
That's cool.
You're doing some other something else smart with your money.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Like buying rims or something like that.
Either way
though.
If you,
uh,
consider like just what lint closet of how do you see anything?
What,
what he's saying and compare it to life,
right?
Where buying house.
Sure.
That's one of many goals you can have in life because life is full.
Like miss it,
but so it Kinda,
when you really think about it,
right,
it's hard.
It's hard to like designate some specific goals and then that's all you're going
to,
okay.
Let's say you're gonna,
you're going to say you're going to be financially secure and independent.
Okay.
That would be a much bigger boss.
Right?
Well,
yeah,
that's an awesome goal.
Bath.
And the younger you make that goal,
the better chance you have of achieving it.
Yeah.
Cause now you're not wasting your money.
You're actually saving for a house so you can get that house paid off.
So now you don't have a mortgage anywhere.
You know?
He's like,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a bigger goal.
That's a broader goal.
Just like when you,
when you go to war,
you need to know what it is you're going to war for.
What are you going to do and when are you going to stop and what's your intended
result?
Yeah.
So you get to,
in a way,
you got to fill your life with a bunch of goals,
Jim.
Cause like if you have small goals that lead to the big goal,
right?
So for instance,
you want to be financially secure and stable.
What are you going to do?
You're going to save some of your money.
Okay,
that's one thing.
And you're going to buy a house.
That's another thing.
You're going to pay off your car and you're not going to buy expensive.
Dumb cars are going to buy cheap cars until you have the money to buy them with
cash.
You know,
you're going to make all these little things.
You're going to work extra,
you're going to,
you know,
you're going to do these things.
So you're right,
you have,
you have your broad goal.
Yes.
You have your longterm goal.
And then you've got your short term goals that lead and are strategically
aligned with that longterm goal.
It's the same thing in war.
You have to have those,
both those things going on.
Yeah.
And then on top of that,
you should have one,
I have the last word today.
Don't you know,
I'm making this
every time I concisely close out what you're trying to say.
You add,
cause it's not that,
I mean it is that,
but then you're talking about life now,
then here,
ears kind of the point where you say,
okay,
you say one example is financial.
Um,
like you want to buy a house,
you want to be financially secure.
That's one goal.
But in life there's more to life than just financial.
So you want your health,
you might your,
you know,
relationships you want,
you're like,
there's all these things that you kind of hope or want to be solid.
We'll say so.
But most people don't really put it in perspective that clearly,
okay,
I,
yes,
you know,
I'm gonna write this down.
I want this goals.
If you have goals,
yes.
If you have goals in those areas,
then you can,
you know,
you can avoid a maneuver towards I'm exactly right.
And avoid distractions,
all this stuff.
Right.
And fight and fight towards those goals.
It sounds obvious,
but that's what I'm saying.
It's like hard to like designate each goal
in life.
Oh,
I didn't say this was going to be easy.
Yeah,
that's the,
it's not that hard.
If you sat down for 20 minutes,
I bet you could come up with some solid life goals.
That's kind of the point I was making where it's you're busy cruising and to
come up with life goals.
Really it's about this being distracted.
I think that's what it is.
You know?
And if the clearer your goal,
the more I think control you can have over being distracted or not.
Cause like if your goal isn't that clear,
it's almost like it's not going to be clear or it is,
you won't really be clear when you're being distracted or not kind of thing.
People don't,
and I'm saying people,
I mean myself,
we don't live our lives like just in constant pursuit of all our specific goals.
It's like a lot of life is minute to minute man.
No,
no,
no.
It is grab telling you a lot of life.
You can have some sections that you can carve out so you can live like that.
But that's not where you are.
I'm not saying this should be how you're rolling.
Yeah,
no,
no.
That's not how it should be.
That's what I'm saying.
So,
and you'll notice in life,
I think like any,
any solid goal that you've achieved,
you'll notice that,
that it took that clear goal and you just didn't get distracted and you just
fought for it.
So it's like you've done it for yourself.
And there's also just like being on the path.
Yeah,
that's what I'm thinking about Jujitsu.
Right.
My goal in Jujitsu was never to get a black belt.
I never said like,
I want to be a black belt in Jiu Jitsu.
It never,
I never even thought that.
Yeah.
I just wanted to get better at this thing.
Right.
Oh,
okay,
so you're not take,
Eddie has never you.
It was never,
my main goal was not to get a black button it,
my goal was to train Jiu Jitsu and get better at Jujitsu and therefore comes,
my goal was like even finances.
I wasn't like,
Hey,
I want to make x amount of money.
I was like,
I want to be able to do whatever I want to do,
so let's move in that direction.
Yeah.
That might not even have a financial value.
Like there's some people that do whatever they want to do,
but they have a very low income,
but they set themselves up in such a way that they're allowed to do what they
pretty much want to do.
Check.
All right.
Are you done?
Last word,
last word anyway?
Oh yeah.
Support.
Right.
That's what we were new.
We were talking about.
All right.
Yeah.
You can surprise them.
I wanted to hear you talk about when you pursue goals you may or may not need
support.
I recommend support supporting yourself,
supportive others from others for others.
Two Way Street.
Okay.
Anyway,
if one of your goals is to maintain physical shape and capability is important.
I work out,
right?
You work out.
Yup.
Right.
Yeah.
Good.
So I work out right.
And you know how so my wife will give me grief sometimes cause I'll just like
work out at the wrong time,
you know,
cause in my mind like working out,
it's important,
right?
So I can like look,
yes,
I can loosely justify,
oh yeah,
you know,
yeah it's dinnertime but hey my health.
Right.
And sometimes little she'll frame it like,
oh yeah,
you choose to like work on your uh,
work on your body or something like that.
And I say,
no,
it's health.
It's capability.
It's true.
But the point there is,
it's important no matter how you frame it or your way frames that it's
important.
Yeah.
You wouldn't do it strategic anyway.
While doing that,
you take krill oil,
take stuff that helps maintain the structural integrity of your body and the
good news is Jocko and supplements for that Krill oil,
Jocko,
super krill and joint warfare.
I've been taking these consistently and solid.
Legit.
Thank you.
Jocko.
Also,
jockey has a new one called discipline.
It's a pre admission if your,
if your mission is a workout,
it's a pre workout.
If your mission is a studying to pre study,
studying,
pre studying supplement,
you know,
pre mission little uh,
cognitive enhancers in there.
A little bit of caffeine,
micro dose,
right?
Like,
yeah.
Yeah.
You don't want to get all strung out on caffeine.
It's just the perfect amount of essentially also if you are owing,
let me tell you where to get these things.
Yeah,
because they're not just floating out there.
Anyway,
I go to origin main.com that's where you get them.
Also an origin main.com you can get cool gies.
A lot of people still know,
still asking me.
Maybe not every day,
maybe not other every other day,
but they still ask me what,
Gee,
should I get?
I started,
did you get to what you should I get here's ones origin geese,
100% not even 99% a hundred percent or dinkies a big range to choose from.
Um,
they also got rash guards in there.
Compression gear for any other activity.
You like some fashion stuff on there too.
Going into fashion style.
Come on,
breathe a little bit.
Little bit at all.
Little bit also.
Oh you mean the plain black victory and may tee shirt and we have,
oh okay.
Cause that's my level of passion.
Well it happened to be on Jocko store.com but I'll get to that first things
first.
Just check if you're doing,
did you say that origin stuff is made here in America?
No big deal.
It's no big deal.
This made in America.
Yeah.
I think it's a big deal but I don't like,
oh you're not going to focus on it
because you know the quality kind of leads with this one or they could go hand
in hand is is it good quality because it's made in America?
Yes.
Is it made in America because it's good quality?
No.
Well,
both
good quality because it's made in America by qualified craftsman.
Yes.
I think that's really the case check.
And some of it is,
one of my buddies just,
uh,
he's,
he was on deployment,
had an origin g shipped over on deployment and he came home from deployment and
he'd been training while he was on deployment and he's like,
Bro,
that origin g is the best thing ever.
And I was like,
yeah,
no.
Yeah,
it is.
for sure.
So anyways,
and it's made in America.
So yeah,
from the cotton,
the cotton that's grown here in America,
what do you call,
uh,
processed here in America?
Woven in America.
Made into,
again,
America.
You can wear it wherever you want,
but it's all,
you can't wear you wherever you are actually more or less with no,
there's certain things you're not allowed to do with your gig.
Yeah,
I agree.
Club,
no.
Geek
grocery store.
No Gay.
Yeah.
Have you ever want to get her grocery store?
No.
Me Neither.
I've never worn my geeky outside of a Jujitsu Academy.
I'm confirming what the boy's brain right now.
What about the kind?
You're either going to Jujitsu or leading you to change their,
yeah,
you change it.
What if I just started rolling in the gay all the time?
Like every wearing outside.
That's awkward.
You know what little kids do it?
Yeah,
that's what it throws the Keon.
She's no problem with that.
Walking around the supermarket.
No,
she's warm.
She's ready.
Representing so geek choke.
Somebody cause he keel.
Wearing a geek in the store can be tactically sound.
You know,
achieving her goals.
Number one,
you gotta demonstrate every once in a while not being distracted.
It's good.
Nonetheless.
You're going to get a GE again.
I'll say it now.
I'll say it again.
All made in America.
In America or domain.com boom.
Select whatever you want.
Get to.
I have two to three actually.
Wait,
no,
then you discipline equals freedom gig.
Got Dalen so three all together.
Boom.
Origin.
You want me to get a black one too?
By the way,
that's you know,
also working out.
You're doing Jujitsu.
Maybe you're doing weightlifting,
maybe you're running,
whatever.
I say do kettle bells and when you do kettle bells,
get the colon from on it on it,
on [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko look for the primal bells.
My opinion actually the Zombie ones are pretty dope too,
but get those.
That's what I think makes it work out more interesting.
I did one yesterday.
It was interesting.
Kind of hard to um,
but nonetheless,
yeah,
get,
get them from there.
They got a lot of cool stuff on there for interesting workouts.
Do you want to switch it up?
If you want to do the same,
like if your workout is boring or something like that,
you'd like to get some battle ropes.
Go through one of those workouts.
You did one like that before or a battle ropes workout before.
Yeah.
Interesting.
It kind of makes your like Seretse kind of sore.
You know what that is?
Your intercostal muscles.
Yeah.
Kinda down there.
None the less anyway on it.com/shop or the three,
get them solid site.
Also when you are getting this book,
we were soldiers once and young.
Actually I thought it was,
we were soldiers once and young and I was like,
wait,
no,
it's,
we were soldiers once and young and young and by the way we were young kind of
thing.
Anyway,
there you get that book.
Good Book.
Outstanding Book.
When you see like my wife will,
we'll do something that there'll be like young seals at.
Yeah.
And my wife's always like,
oh,
they look so young.
They look so young.
You know?
And that's what you always think.
You just think that these kids are so young.
And then I was one of those kids and yeah,
they are young.
That's who fights wars.
Young kids.
1819 2022 years old.
23 years old.
That's who fights wars.
Yeah.
And it's crazy.
And Jp kind of talks about this where your maturity kind of gets on this like
fast track when you jumped in the military.
It doesn't,
it doesn't.
It doesn't.
Because you're also institutionalized.
Oh yeah.
That's true.
You don't like when you're in the middle.
That's what hurts some guys when they get out of the military,
they're like,
wait a second,
I don't wait.
Where's my paycheck is?
What's to come every two weeks now it's not there anymore.
They used to it.
Oh you have a mission.
Here's what you're gonna do in that.
When you're in the military,
you just,
here's your clothes that you're going to wear.
You know what I mean?
It makes sense.
Here's the haircut that you're going to have when you get out of the military.
Also in,
you're like,
you don't have this direction anymore.
So you do get,
it matures you in some ways,
but in other ways you get stunted growth.
That's why he gets him guys doing dumb shit when they're 30 years old,
38 years old,
42 years old.
They're doing the midlife crisis thing.
But when you think when you,
maybe it's not even a mid level,
they're just trying to figure it out cause they just haven't had,
right.
They didn't do that like at the time as everyone else.
But you know how you talk about your wife looks at it.
The younger guys or the seals didn't say oh they look so young that I think
that's like an indicator that she doesn't feel old.
You know,
cause you know how like when you're,
when you kind of look like I do the same thing when I look at college football,
when I watch college football,
cause I remember when I was,
when I was playing football wise,
oh yeah there is a day 26 years old on meeting 26
school.
Yeah.
It didn't help.
It was kind of going bald and stuff like that.
But nonetheless he's 26 26 is young by the way.
And depending on how old you are because when you're 16 you don't think,
if I tried to ask my son who's 15 like what,
what,
how far away?
25 years or how,
how long was it until he was 25 like he oh would understand 10 years he has no,
he would not be able to like cognitively assess what a 25 year old human being
is.
Thinking about these 15 all access.
Not got it going on.
Yeah.
But I feel like you'd still be able to figure out,
okay,
25 you know,
people,
when do people die of old age,
quote unquote would be what,
eighties
discipline,
you know,
whenever,
so you figured 25 it's what?
Less than a 30 year life,
26 less than a third that would it be considered old technically if they were to
think about,
I think 1515 year old would grasp that even the 26 year old was old.
He was,
yeah,
I thought so.
So when I look back and then me,
I don't feel old as old as I am,
I don't feel like,
oh old.
I think back when I was in college or whatever,
and I think about the,
the number of my current age and I think,
Dang,
that's,
that's all that's an older person being that older person now I don't feel like
how I thought that older person would have felt right.
And I really think that now it really comes in,
gets put into perspective.
When I watch college football and I seem to take off their helmet and like Dang,
that is a child right there playing college football,
performing,
outperforming like super good.
But they just look so young.
I'm just like your wife,
they look so young.
But it's because I don't feel like an old person.
That's what,
that's good.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Because you know if you feel like whole person you're like,
yeah,
they'd look down because they're young.
They're,
I'm an old person there.
You know,
you feel like you,
she could be in there too and they're like,
oh yeah.
And then you see,
okay he's,
he's young and I'm old.
You know,
just one of those things on the last back to support
when you buy this book,
we were soldiers once and young.
Go to Jocko,
podcast.com we've got a section that all the books that this book listed by
episode,
all the books listen by episode plus a few other ones.
Boom.
Click through there.
We got you taste,
you direct link,
Amazon prime.
You have prime,
right?
I do one day shipping,
same day she ran sometimes.
Anyway,
get it there.
Good way to support and if you're going to do other shopping,
carry on.
Good way to support.
Also Jack was the store
and I'm going to talk about it,
but before I do that,
I think if you subscribed to the podcast as good way to support what I was going
to say,
subscribe if you haven't already,
seems obvious,
but subscribe,
leave a review on iTunes.
If you subscribe to Itunes,
if you want to leave a review,
if you're feeling reluctant,
just get over it.
Leave the review.
Also Youtube,
subscribe to the Youtube video version of this podcast.
Also excerpts,
various types of excerpts.
Um,
you know,
so you can share so you don't,
if you don't want to share the whole two and a half hour podcast with people,
there are excerpts.
If you wanted to share an individual,
a concept with people,
they can boom,
they can get that concept and you know,
share it,
internalize it.
You know what I mean?
Also Jack was the store.
It's called chocolate store.
drugstore.com shirts,
tee shirts,
rash guards,
hoodies,
some patches on their hats on.
They're just,
it's the stuff I'll say,
it's cool stuff.
I wouldn't be pushing stuff that I didn't think it was cool
and it's chocolate proved kind of the pink shirts aren't Jaquobe know.
But nonetheless nonetheless,
if you want to get shirts and stuff that that's where it is.
Jacqueline's store.com uh,
they are good stuff.
They are good.
They're not like the cheap ones is what I'm saying.
So boom,
you can rest assured.
But yeah,
tell me what you think.
If you have one.
Hey,
people take pictures of themselves with the shirt on and they say this is a good
shirt and that's good.
I encourage that.
And if you don't like the shirt,
let me know too.
There it is also good way to support yourself.
One of the better ways in my opinion,
depends on what kind of person you are,
is psychological warfare.
If you don't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks with Jocko on each track telling you that in your,
on your campaign against weakness.
When you read,
when you hit those roadblocks,
that's what it is.
Rope.
That's what they are.
Roadblocks,
mental fatigue,
uh,
distractions,
all this stuff.
These tracks will help you through it.
It's chocolate telling you pragmatically giving you practical information and
advice.
How to get over those roadblocks or around those roadblocks or through those
roadblocks.
Psychological warfare track that's going to be directed towards you or make you
talk about this stuff faster.
Okay.
Well,
here's the thing.
When I,
you know,
I come across this,
uh,
smart,
right?
Yeah.
See,
I feel compelled to share the valuable points that I think are valuable that
I've used or that I felt with each thing.
But then I'm like,
oh wait,
that'll take a long time to explain.
So sometimes like sometimes I go with it.
You don't seem to,
sometimes they don't,
but today I'm giving you a down jacket.
No,
no,
no.
I think it's valuable.
Okay,
we'll go with that.
Now Watch how fast I do this.
Yeah,
but you're not going to give him the whole thing.
You know,
like the Jocko white tea.
You don't,
you didn't demonstrate.
Not Demonstrate.
Explain.
Yeah.
Did Jocko white tea guaranteed to get your dead lift to 8,000 pounds.
Boom.
That's it.
Done next.
There's three books you can get where the warrior kid gets kids on the path.
Boom.
Done.
Actually motor shop.
More bone.
That's cool.
No need.
I don't know men,
but I think like I read way the word kid to my daughter every single night.
It's one or two chapters,
not too long,
just one or two chapters.
So she wants to read the next chapter she wanted,
she wants me to read the next chapter that night.
I said no tomorrow.
She's looking forward to it every single night.
That's just the mantra.
The whole way of the warrior kid is just a background mood for life.
Yes.
Good thing to know.
Don't be weak like work hard,
all this stuff.
What would explain that whole thing
does it cause that's the value that I got
where the warrior kid,
if you want a longer explanation you can email echo and he'll give it to you.
Extreme ownership.
Same thing.
Combat leadership for business and life.
That's new version.
Just came out has a little Q and a from you all from the podcast that's in
there,
so you can get that.
Also from an individual perspective,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
It's available everywhere.
There's no better gift than discipline.
The audio version of that,
which people ask me about a lot is not on audible.com it is on,
it's,
it's an album with tracks.
Actually.
You can get it from iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
other MP3 platforms for leadership.
Also beyond the podcast,
beyond the books,
we have a leadership consultant company.
It's me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
You can email info@ashevilleonfront.com if you want to book a speaker,
don't call speakers bureau or a speaker's agent.
Don't just go to issue echelon front.com.
Fill out the form and one of us will come talk to you and your company.
On top of that,
we got something called the muster,
also known as the monster.
We're doing two of them this year only.
Why we don't have enough room in the schedule to do three again,
Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th San Francisco,
California,
October 17th and 18th
come and get it.
Extreme ownership.com that's where you register.
There's some video stuff about it
that that's that
also if you want to ask us more questions or do you have answers to questions or
points to make outside of the podcast and you want to get in touch with us,
you can do it on the Inter webs Twitter,
Instagram
at that phase you book.
That is where you can find us.
Echo is at Echo Charles and I m at Jocko Willink and to those people out there,
the soldiers,
sailors,
airmen and marines around the world right now standing watch.
Thank you for protecting our nation and our freedoms and a police and law
enforcement.
Thanks for watching our backs here at home and protecting us from evil in our
own backyard
to the firefighters that walk into fire.
Okay.
To keep us safe and the paramedics that keep us alive.
First responders,
thanks to all of you for what you do and to everyone out there.
Okay.
Made sure you have a plan,
okay.
Make sure you have a goal.
Make sure you have intent,
make sure you have a mission,
and then get out there
and get after it.
Okay.
Until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.